[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a fallu quelques jours pour
que les gens se calment était déjà dans
sa maison fermée et il commencera comme
sentir pour penser et rencontrer votre
en couple ou seul et le besoin naît
de personnes à acheter ce type de
produits l'augmentation a été
considérable environ 50 pour cent
pour cent de ce que nous venions généralement
vente
[Musique]
bien qu'alors aussi comme recherché par
le sujet des jouets sexuels en tant que
complément de sorte que bien que la flamme de
passion ou tout ce qui touche au sujet
sexuel ne devient pas si monotone et
plus sur le thème du confinement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]